hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see rogue one
a lot of you had Darth Vader questions
and the Lucasfilm people have actually
come out and answered a bunch of them so
they're just gonna explain the Darth
Vader scenes there's a new round of the
Star Wars giveaway I'm still giving away
IMAX tickets so all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss anything
so there were a lot of Darth Vader
questions after this movie we arguably
got the best Darth Vader scene in any
Star Wars movie at the very end but
there was a lot of questions about the
lava planet where his castle is which
was the only planet in the movie that
did not get a subtitle everywhere they
went they had like a little heading that
told you where you were part of the
reason I think they chose not to
subtitle this is just to make you wonder
so if you're a big star Wars fan you
probably recognized it and thought about
moves too far in what that could
possibly mean because they just blows
your mind like why would Darth Vader
choose to live in a place that
represented so many painful memories for
him and then there's also the thing you
know just where you see him living on a
lava planet and you're like oh my god
this planet is so hardcore Darth Vader
so hardcore so it's just cool from a
visual standpoint the castle itself just
looks badass but here's the deal with
that so that there are really two huge
Darth Vader scenes there are a couple
other smaller scenes but the two real
big scenes were on Moo stefarr and then
later at the end when he goes all
Armistice from the end of Westworld so
starting with the lava planet a lot of
you guessed seeing the movie like I said
that this is moose too far but the
Lucasfilm people that were answering
questions about the cannon after the
movie came out just said that Darth
Vader chose this place because there is
so much conflict in him it's meant to
represent the idea that they're still
good in him so he chooses to live here
to just punish himself on purpose
because he's so conflicted they kind of
did that in a really ham-fisted way with
kylo Ren during episode 8 there's so
much conflict in me you need to help me
Father help me choose one side or the
other so this is Darth Vader doing that
same kylo Ren thing where he's like
teetering on the edge like he's not
completely bad but he's not good either
so just like he is on the precipice his
castle is on the precipice of this cliff
here with lava flowing all around so
it's also a good metaphor
for his emotional state - and then of
course the bhakta tank is just a visual
reference for Empire Strikes Back where
you see him in his chamber without the
helmet on like oh my god what does he
look like underneath all that armor and
for Luke Skywalker who gets stuck in the
bhakta tank so there's just a lot of
visual metaphors like you don't need a
lot of dialogue I always feel like the
best Darth Vader scenes are ones that do
not involve dialogue like the one at the
end
best Darth Vader scene in any Star Wars
movie
he doesn't speak it off he just pops the
lightsaber and crushes everyone so that
is why I was a little disappointed with
the dialogue in the puns when he was
talking to cranek in the base don't get
crushed by the weight of your own
ambitions I mean it was a badass Vader
moment but I felt like they didn't need
to use the pun in the acolyte that a lot
of people were wondering about they're
like is this Snoke here like who is this
person that comes to help him out so
this is not Snoke it's probably just
someone like Donnie yen's character from
a darkside perspective someone who
serves the force but serves the dark
side of the force more like an acolyte
but maybe not as powerful as that the
emperor has a lot of servants that might
be force sensitive but aren't dark jedi
themselves there was a really cool rumor
this hasn't been confirmed but a lot of
people thought that maybe they didn't
subtitle this planet because it's going
to come back in Episode eight because
unless Mustafar was blown up by the
Death Star it still exists it's still
out there somewhere
so we might get to see it again via kylo
Ren's character as he's training because
if he's such a vader fanboy and keeps
the melted remains of his helmet with
him at all times and speaks did wouldn't
he also travel to all the places that
Vader had lived
Somu stefarr itself is very strong in
the dark side of the force Darth Vader
lived there for a long time so it just
makes sense that kylo Ren would either
have gone there or we will go back there
through his character as he tries to
complete his Darkseid training
there's been an awakening have you felt
it yes
even you
master of the Knights of Ren have never
faced such a test by the grace of your
training I will not be seduced we shall
see we shall see the fuel cells of
rocket the collapse of the planet has
begun lose the base at once and come to
me with kylo Ren it is time to complete
his training so we have to talk about
Darth Vader at the end of rogue one
versus Episode four a lot of people are
like why is he such a badass at the end
of this movie but in Episode four he can
barely fight it's almost like he's super
weak it's almost like he forgot to fight
somewhere in the couple of days that
have gone by between these movies
because Episode four picks up just a
heartbeat after the end of rogue one so
you know what happened to all the skills
what's the deal here so a lot of this
just goes into the fight choreography in
just the way they planned it out they
just weren't able to do something that
was technically quite as masterful and
they say that on the set like even Mark
Hamill says that when they were fighting
with lightsabers George Lucas was really
draconian about how they were allowed to
use them they were more like kendo
swords the ones that you wield with two
hands when they were on the set of Jedi
filming Mark Hamill said that they were
getting ready for their big final fight
they were rehearsing and he asked Lucas
can we just use one hand we can actually
do a much cooler fight if you let us use
one hand to wield the lightsabers and
Lucas was like absolutely not you have
to use two hands so it really limited
the types of moves that they could do at
the time but nowadays Hollywood fight
choreography has got a lot more dynamic
it's taken inspiration from a lot of
Eastern films so with the evolution of
that as well as the evolution of digital
effects they're just able to more fully
realize what Darth Vader should be able
to do on screen so when Yuri watch the
original trilogy films just imagine that
Darth Vader is every bit this badass but
they just weren't able to do that when
they were actually filming these movies
so it's not that he can't fight it's
just that they weren't able to film it
the way they wanted to a lot of you've
asked about a Darth Vader spin-off film
like
they're doing spin-off films why don't
we do Darth Vader he's one of the best
characters of all time I definitely
agree with that statement and I think
the best explanation for why we're not
going to get a Darth Vader spin-off film
is that final scene it's just so amazing
so brief so Vader is best when he's used
like that in a very scarce way just bits
and pieces you can bring him in he'll do
something super creepy super badass so
you guys can let me know how do you want
them to continue to use Darth Vader in
the future spin-off films if they're set
during the original trilogy timeline the
next film is about a young Han Solo
arguably if they don't change the
timeline that would be happening like a
couple years before the events of rogue
one meaning that Anakin Skywalker would
have been Darth Vader for at least a
couple years he was anointed Darth Vader
about 19 years before the events of
rogue one so you have to remember that
if Han Solo is going to be say like 26
in his film or you know like in his
mid-20s then Darth Vader would be in his
mid to late 30s so just because that's
gonna be a han Solo movie I'm not
expecting to see a whole lot of Jedi or
anything like that but because it's
happening before the Death Star is built
jeddah
has been destroyed there might be like a
few jedi floating around but i'm not
expecting to see any lightsabers or
anything like that
hokey religions and ancient weapons were
no match for a good blaster at your side
kid you don't believe in the force do
you kid I've flown from one side of this
galaxy to the other I've seen a lot of
strange stuff but I've never seen
anything to make me believe there's one
all-powerful force controlling
everything there's no mystical energy
field controls my destiny it's all a lot
of simple tricks and nonsense
it's all true well let me know how you
want the saga films like episode 8
episode 9 to continue to invoke Darth
Vader I'm not expecting to see Anakin's
force ghost anytime soon most of the
Darth Vader that the films have invoked
have been through kylo ren's character
so that really just comes in the form of
him staring at the melted helmet with
weird atmospheric creepy music in the
background so hopefully because Ray was
retracing Luke Skywalker steps as she
was trying to find him
maybe we'll see kylo Ren
retracing a lot of Darth Vader steps but
I'll say congratulations to this week's
Star Wars giveaway winner grant Carlson
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there is a new round
that started with this video so we'll
just announce the winner the next time I
post a Star Wars video while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for all my rogue one Easter eggs and you
can click here for a Rick and Morty Star
Wars Death Star parody thank you so much
for watching everybody let's I bought
I'll see you guys tonight me me me me
[Music]